thank you
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where we
are indeed very careful boys and today I
have an OTR prompt which is would you be
intimidated if you found out your chick
had done pornography in the past oh dude
how is that [__] with now imagine now
the Heavenly now the good now you love
the Hem you love the Geo you love the
tip you love the snacks snacks snacks
you love you Nina but now you know you
love Nikki for some snacks and you know
Geo had a Geo oh
right I would be so disappointed because
I know she wasn't famous because I
watched all of them
at about her ranking yeah I think I
would be like for Star meter yeah why
the [__] didn't you jump on only fans
sooner when everyone was making hella
money yeah you'd be disappointed yeah so
these guys would be disappointed
um I think I would be definitely like
I'd be
I'd be sad not sad but I'd be from a
trust point of view well for one she'd
be under eight I'd be super insecure I'd
be hell insecure dude oh [__] High
School
good at that math but not the other kind
of math age stuff
consent stuff he could just he's like a
Texas
Instruments around him but he's got the
age
he's like [__] gonna Abacus look at
sliding around
I got Siri all the time about the age of
consent why what's the most popular he's
just curious he's just curious you've
said that I should do that for every
country I go to people don't watch all
the videos and sequins that's why people
said some random [__]
yeah dude thank you for watching you're
a [__] fan piece of [__] would you be
would you be sexually jealous yes
because for me I I first first I'd have
to critique her work yes I'd be mad
cause I'm like you were not transparent
with me
and after having sex with you
you didn't use any of your talented
skills that you probably did if you were
if you're a skill star so true because
then you didn't [__] me like a porn star
you [__] me like you love me yeah can
I just just watch your works of art so
true and I'd have to study and watch it
I'm like you know what if it if she did
moves in those movies that didn't happen
to me I'd be so yeah you'd be hurt so
hurt I'm fighting bro I'd be like dude
like come on ultimately you just hurt
you tugged him and licked his balls I
didn't get that
so it's more of a sexual thing like like
uh how come you didn't do that to me I
think that could be one aspect but what
if they did that what if you did say
like it's because I love you I didn't
love them this isn't that like getting
pounded by like seven dudes yeah I don't
know if it would matter
it was one more it was eight oh my God
I'm out yeah
and then you're like okay okay you're
not a you're not a [__] sucker but it's
cool bar would be like we were broken up
right she doesn't suck dick she doesn't
do any of that stuff and then she goes
oh but I was actually in porn and I suck
dick but that's because I'm performing I
don't I don't [__] suck dick yeah I
would be like you you let the strangers
have it yeah yeah yeah Joe would have
been like so how much then
what do I got to do
yeah everybody's got a number I'm being
the real me oh cool yeah you're gonna
fart around me too what the [__]
that's not what I wanted out of this oh
I would have been so like this is I
don't even know you anymore I'm telling
you you know so then you'd break up then
no no just get to know her again I just
be like hang on didn't say that hold on
let me get some more money those
performances were awesome like what the
[__] can I meet her yeah yeah
turn it on
but then I don't think it's I don't
think it's like something you should
break up with someone for I think the
the line so if it was a past life that
it's you probably should disclose like
like even if she was a drug dealer it's
like or she she'd been to jail once or
like some of these things or just being
in debt like you kind of want to
disclose those things before you get
into a major serious relationship that
might lead into like marriage and family
building but could you handle it could
you really sit there and handle it like
if you knew your tricks out there and
there's like vids of her getting
slamming slam a gem yeah
obviously ridiculous I I actually am
tracking on that sentiment of like if
you were to see those pornos and the way
that she performed in that it was just
like a whole different Starlight that'd
be so sad and you didn't have that then
you would feel it would feel really
jarring yeah you would have to prepare
hypothetically let's say you're like
constantly having sex with a girl and
you're like damn dude I don't know if I
can hang she's [__] Like a Porn Star
you you had no idea and then you saw
where the scale came from later then
it's really about the trust and [__]
versus my security yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that makes sense that's true that's
right because you're like duh no wonder
she [__] like that she's so good yeah
like a porn star yeah it's because she
was versus like man she's [__] like
she loves me
it almost seems like she [__] me like
she loves me down here
yeah yeah
that's very can you [__] me like you
don't love me I think that's better
make love to me can you just [__] me you
don't know me or something
if you actually found out that Hannah's
like hand
[Music]
[Laughter]
no because out of this room I'm probably
the most
like closest person that'll date a
hooker and a [__] stripper so true
yeah
but at the same time it's not his brand
though you know it's not his brand look
don't don't do that she doesn't be now
the fine establishment like data hooker
and a stripper yeah that's not my brand
name
yeah I'm a drink maker but the key word
is past I'm a cash register
the key word is passed that's perfect
because okay still sucking dick that's
difficult like how Kazumi and her
boyfriend can do that I'm like you guys
have a very mature like not jealous
relationship like when I look at your
situation I'm like no I can't do that
that's my turn what if it's like a
vigilante though what if she's got like
a whole mask on and it's like a whole
Alter Ego no you know what I mean it's
not hint it's like something completely
different you don't want buildings and
[__] guy [__] [__] yeah we've got
Fox mask so you're talking about like
going up buildings with dudes inside of
them like those porn PornHub creators
that don't show their face like those
ones yeah that's pretty cool so you
would never know and then she was just
like you know I go buy this Alias I'm
actually you know
how long was it in the past
and if they're currently doing it if
they're currently doing it I think
that's way more hurtful you think that's
a betrayal if they're currently you
think that's really that bad I don't get
it
I can't relate dude that's very bad you
know I want to do Anthony what about
what if if Nina is like Neath
right you did not do that to Hannah
that was so [__] this was like a
[__] warm-up that was like a home run
I'm just saying like what that what if
that was important
you're getting special treatment lucky
you [__] dude do I not say that
smacks have snacks
yeah yeah come on I'm being fair what if
that was the case what do you do we're
all getting it we're all getting it
pretty bad oh that's pretty bad Shut the
[__] up
um what's the question again
you know what I know what that question
is if you know she did it how could you
could you hang you found all of these
videos of UC Irvine yeah yeah if I found
them girls oh dude that would be the
worst
it's not even like
telling me about it like a confession
that would be the worst of course I
wouldn't be able to handle that would
you confront her would you be like hey
like I gotta know like are you neat
like are you is that you
oh my God
oh my God bro the fact that it was not
said that way I see you or else she goes
who that's not me let's say this again
please do not make a short out of this
I said that today hey I got whoa I got
Anthony bingo I got Anthony Bingo
respect Anthony these guys oh my God
he's the best straight man we got
in the business
there's no winning here dude hey check
out the pennies of our checks into his
wall the best timing the best choices
yeah the way you sit in it dude can I
deflect an answer Laster or something
like that I'm very she so she brings it
up to you there's something even I need
to tell you we're we're public with our
marriage now
one last secret I gotta share so and
when I tell you my name it's gonna sound
like I'm coming I'm not I was faking it
it's my name it said porn dialect
s
um
I'm a fairly interesting simulator is
she wearing an alias in all the videos
where you can't see her face and it's
not really like not everybody would be
able to recognize say no so everybody
can see her I know that I do not want
that's the one like so like a random a
random homie can come up to me and be
like dude
ah this is the hardest thing I could
ever say to you can I dab you up a
little bit Yeah like is it like that
where somebody else would know yes then
yeah that would that would be a line
Crosser I think it would be it wouldn't
be over but I think we would have a lot
of work to do is it because you don't
want them to see her [__]
are you that
spoken like a true medical doctor dude
the way Joseph said that on the left
field God just caught me off guard
whereas for example just a just to paint
the picture because I'm a good sport
with this whack-ass conversation whoa
whoa it's a problem I'm with you
answering next that's all I gotta say
yeah dude
first okay supporting you um versus
let's say she was uh you know hidden
character Alias like like you know
Batman or [__] like that right and a
woman a come woman sure
um then and nobody could recognize her
and it's a private understanding outside
of maybe all the like the giant dicks
that [__] her yeah I think it's just
less work I think it's more like we got
conditions now it's like one don't do
that again number two you better [__] me
with that mask on number three like
really you know what I'm saying like I I
think if no if nothing else really got
harmed outside of like that truly was
her past and it was a very difficult
thing I don't even know why I'm trying
to rationalize this
um but you're being empathetic yeah but
like if nothing else changed in our
current world then I would we would have
less work is all to to get back to a
place of like both trust and enjoyment
because there's there are some if I want
to be extra pathetic there are some
positives that could come out of it in
the future for us that's right like what
three Subs that's what he's thinking
about he's like you were a poor star you
probably know some freaks can you can
you get some other girls because like
I'm trying to get my balls licked when
my dick is getting stuck at the same
time
I'm trying to be optimistic here you
know what I mean like like what kind of
wins can I get from this you're like did
you do that did you ever do the lesbian
scenes because I would like to see yeah
I'm just trying to balance my losses
that's all I'm not trying to win on top
I'm trying to balance my losses it's
like 2022 all over again yeah you hear
the Tiger
uh all right Nick your turn uh that's I
think it would be really hard do you
need the prompt again yeah from the top
and no no
what name
Bingo his changes everything because
then it's like she wasn't a virgin then
but it was also but yeah I think that
should become a porn star after she had
sex with him
he sought it out she was like I gotta
change my career imagine imagine if you
guys were in high school sweethearts
because it's illegal so you're now
College sweetheart yeah I think if I
were to meet her back then and I were to
find out like early in a relationship I
think I'd be [__] probably dunzo see
I told you it's the time frame the time
the time is definitely a thing but then
also because what if she was like in six
years ago I had a pass yeah I think I
think for me particularly
based on like the way we got together I
think it would be really hard for me to
move forward even now not not now I
think like it would be hard for me but
it's like it's probably my own [__] I
gotta work out on like how I feel about
it like that's probably what I would
have to work on it's because you're like
I didn't have half as many dicks as she
did yeah like I only got a couple under
my belt yeah I mean
what Earnest she's like hey like I want
you to know like I only did anal so like
mine yeah yeah yeah that's like that's
okay that's kind of
[__]
on Saturday honestly because no matter
what you look at it as a guy
trying to date somebody or marry
somebody you don't want to have videos
of them having sex with some other
people on the internet you generally
don't generally would you rather have a
hooker I'd be of a hot take but I'm just
saying it's kind of judgy but yeah yeah
it's kind of judging because a hooker
Never Had video of them so does that
make a difference yeah they're like I
used to be a hooker look a rule it does
that's why this isn't about a hooker
but it's someone that had a lot of sex
yeah for performance this is pointing to
the Excel sheet prop that he touched it
he's all hey I'm powerless in this
situation I can't do anything I didn't
change it I'm asleep
it says what it says all right fine Alex
Resurrection you're in control man I'm
telling you yeah
but as far as like being with Tiff and
like how good our relationship is and
all that [__] and how hard we've like
you know come together I think it's it's
one of those things where it's like yeah
it's worth to try to [__] make it
work you know I mean when your guys's
[__] ass [__] want to ask you if
you'll still love me if I'm a worm you
guys is going to fail that question a
worm at what point do they ask that no
girls they like hey if I was still a
[__] worm would you love me and [__]
girls do that [__] all the time yeah if
I was a worm it's like hey like if I
broke my leg and like you had to take
care of it my [__] never asked me the
worm question
so that they do that [__] my [__] does
the work
he's doing well
yeah bro I think I think you would uh I
think either way you're just taking an L
bro you're taking an L you're taking a
huge out is it a capital l you got a
balance you gotta balance the [__]
you gotta balance it depending how you
feel about it but is it the okay but is
it the [__] that hurts your feeling
or is it more like the lying that hurts
your feelings I think it's a [__]
because for me it's the line oh
okay no it's the combination of
everything I expect I expect I expect
them to be sucking dick and [__]
that's normal yeah yeah yeah sexual
jealousy is like by the time you're an
older person it's like it should it
should go away right but then like I
will be so much more hurt that they
didn't share this with me because
they're afraid of the money instead of
the profits that's a good one yeah that
too but no like you know that does
change it if she's like [__] just got
this crazy bacon there's another bank
account that you didn't know about that
had millions of dollars it's like hey
you know that's totally different I'm
like okay you know the sheets are a
little bit more balanced but dude if you
if you found videos and she didn't say
nothing to you that would destroy me bro
that I think that would just wreck
everything I would jack off to it once
and then from there I couldn't find it
that's exactly what it's gonna do yeah
well I think I think it's hard to come
back
it's hard to come back well I think you
can but it's tough I cried and jack off
and then go okay but you know Kanye fell
in love with uh Kim Kardashian by
watching the sex and he kept watching it
over and over yeah he turned out great
now he just hates Jewish people because
he watched another video yeah so I know
I know that had been the last video we
ever saw I know that uh you know she's
not subscribed to this channel so that's
not what I'm worried about but I know
that her mom follows us and watches
these videos so she's like my son's a
cuck so I just want to remind you that's
Alex resurrection's fault it's not none
of us can control what we talk about
here there's prompts Alex you gotta Alex
is
if it happened if it happened in the
past are you still a [__] cup because
you're watching your woman get railed by
another man if you're watching energy
for sure but it's in the past though but
the videos made in the past and you're
in the present isn't it kind of in the
cuck Lane it's adjacent I don't even
cook adjacent yeah it's cook adjacent I
think I think you're a step away like
aren't you putting on a cuck Bib and
sucking on a cuck Lolly yeah while
you're watching this what if what if you
catch it and it's uh it's just a
Japanese guy in the porno with her just
like unshaved very small Japanese male
doing the porno with pixelation heavy
pixelation that means he's from Japan
because all their dicks are they're born
that way it's okay when I had Fallout
lunch and I had Rami and you guys like
that's really authentic and I'm like
cool
[Laughter]
I go skip out on half steps like that
drove up like that yeah if I saw that
and I'll be like damn dude
she must really like me if she railed
all these dudes and she still chooses me
that's a good way to think about it yeah
that's a great way to trick yourself
yeah
or she saddled with me because those
guys didn't want to keep her
it's all a [__] professional Endeavor
okay it has nothing to do with Romance
that's true by the way we're not shaming
porn stars here we're just hoping our
chicks didn't do it
please so there's a risk and there's a
difference
why do we do this to ourselves there's a
big difference it's a good prompt though
thanks Alex for writing us
[Music]
foreign